resuelve la ecuación 5 entre 2 x menos 4
entre 3 x es igual a 7 entre 18 para x
distinto de 0 y nos dicen que x es
distinto de 0 porque si no estas dos
expresiones serían expresiones con
denominador 0 y estaríamos dividiendo
entre 0 lo cual no se puede pero bueno
con un poco de suerte al resolver la
ecuación x va a quedar distinto de 0
entonces esto sería nada más información
adicional bueno vamos a ver cómo se
resuelve
para empezar aquí hay demasiados
denominadores y no me gustan los
denominadores no me gusta que la x esté
aquí abajo y en general no me gusta que
haya fracciones así que lo que vamos a
hacer es encontrar algunas expresiones
de modo que al multiplicar de ambos
lados por esas expresiones se cancelen
los denominadores desaparezcan vale
bueno en realidad van a pasar como
arriba pero vamos a ver cómo se hace
esto déjame escribir la expresión acá
para tener un poco más de espacio
voy a poner 5
dividido entre 2x
menos -4
/ 3x es igual a
7 entre 18 y 7 entre 18 bueno imagínate
que queremos eliminar estos
denominadores para eliminar este 2
necesitaríamos multiplicar esta igualdad
por 2 para eliminar este 3
necesitaríamos multiplicar por 3 y para
eliminar este 18 necesitaríamos
multiplicar por 18 pero si multiplicamos
por 18 ese 18 ya tiene un 2 y un 3 la
factorización de 18 es la siguiente 18
entre 2 99 entre 3 da a 3 entonces
multiplicar por 18 es multiplicar por 12
y por 23 es bueno entonces vamos a
multiplicar por 18 todo aquí por 18 aquí
por 18 y aquí también por 18 pero
también queremos que se eliminen estas
equis que están en los denominadores
entonces también voy a multiplicar por x
entonces estoy multiplicando toda la
igualdad por 18 x podemos pensar que
este 18 x vino del mínimo común múltiplo
de 2 de 12 x 3x y 18 el menor número que
sea múltiplo de
23 bueno vamos a realizar estas
multiplicaciones saber que nos queda la
primera la voy a hacer en verde x se
cancela con x 18 entre 2 es 9 y 9 por 5
es 45
luego a eso tengo que restar lo voy a
hacer en este color rosa x se cancela
con x 18 entre 13 6 y 6 por 4 es 24
y eso es igual a déjame tomar el color
rosa mexicano 18 se cancela con 18 7 por
x es 7 x 7 x muy bien ahora vamos a
hacer esta resta 45 menos 24 es igual a
21 21 y entonces 21 es igual a 7 x y
dividiendo entre 7 de ambos lados nos
queda que x es igual a 21 entre 7 y 21
entre 7 estrés entonces x es igual a 3
muy bien lo voy a poner por acá x es
igual a 3 y podemos verificar que en
efecto x igual a 3 es una solución para
eso déjame sustituir x igual a 3 en esta
expresión de acá lo voy a hacer en color
naranja
entonces nos quedaría 5 entre 2 por
equis o sea 2 x 3
- 4 / 3 por equis o sea tres por tres
bueno vamos a realizar esta esta
operación de esta resta de fracciones
esto es igual a cinco sextos menos
4 sobre 9 4 novenos
buscamos mínimo común múltiplo el mínimo
común múltiplo de 6 y de 9 18 entonces
aquí nos quedaría / 18 - y otra cosa
también entre 18 6 x 13 18 entonces el
numerador también hay que multiplicarlo
por 3 nos queda 15 9 por 2 es 18
entonces 4 lo multiplicamos por 2 y
haciendo la resta nos queda 15 menos 8
entre 18 y eso es igual es igual a 7
entre 18 justo como queríamos
justo como queríamos entonces en efecto
x es igual a 3 y esto lo que nos dice es
que al sustituir x en esta expresión nos
queda 7 entre 18 y con esto terminamos